all right miss Demi hi it's been a big
week it has been been crazy
has it been crazy I mean tell me how
it's felt to share your truth with the
world on a platform like bachelor in
paradise I think it just feels really
liberating and it shows that just be
yourself and it's okay we've heard your
truth now had you dated other women
before Christian did anybody else on
Colton season kind of know that you were
fluid I have dated other women in the
past like I started my freshman year
casually dating and stuff and no one on
Colton season knew at the time I you
know was afraid of what they might think
I didn't know these girls and you know
just all the fear that comes with that
but after the season and I got really
close of course I told some of them well
how do you feel now do you feel relieved
no more fear no more fear I feel
liberated and I'm glad that I can just
set an example that it's okay to be
yourself I would imagine both some
positivity and some more negative
commentary yeah I would say that the
majority of it has been positive and
it's been really good to hear all of
that you know it's like everyone and a
hundred thousand people has something
negative to say so yeah I'm not worried
about it
well you're not somebody who lets people
come at you with their negativity you
fire back a little bit yeah sometimes I
fire back a little too hard how are you
regulating yourself on when to come back
at somebody and when to just ignore it
I think it's just best to ignore it it
all right now yeah a lot of drama in
Paradise this season period yeah exactly
I'm I'm a little overwhelmed with all
the drama I don't need anymore
before this season you teased to me that
it would be a dumpster fire yeah and I
think you were right yeah it was the
dumpster fire is how would you describe
it now is is the dumpster fire ablaze
like how's the fire I would say the
dumpster fire is I got a good it's like
sizzling like a slow simmer right now
like we just were boiling the water now
we're at a simmer okay we're to simmer
yeah but is there gonna be more fire
like I do we have more left in this
season of course it's paradise very nice
it's far from paradise yeah so I want to
ask you a little bit about you and
Christian because we now have seen you
guys be together on the show but tell me
more about your relationship before the
show how did you meet and how long had
you been together we met through
Agro because Christian is her roommate
another bachelor nation alone yes so we
met through her and we were just two
humans enjoying each other's company I'd
always known that I was gonna go on
paradise and so I was up front with her
about that whenever we first met so we
both agreed to keep it open not
exclusive well that's what I was
wondering because when she came to
paradise
you seemed really happy to see each
other and it didn't give an indication
that you'd had a bad breakup or
something did you actually break up
before you went to paradise or were you
in an exclusive thing we were never
really together so there was nothing to
break up it was just like I'm open I'm
still gonna be open I could go to
Paradise and I might fall in love with
someone and you like she was okay with
that but yeah so whenever I saw her I
had no idea that the feelings were so
strong until like we were finally like
reunited did you have any idea that she
might show up in paradise no I thought I
was leaving I thought that Chris was
taking me up there to say all right go
get her go get her like home oh yeah
because you said I want to talk to Chris
what did you want to say to Chris were
you ready to leave the show I was at the
point where I was ready to leave the
show if that's what my only option was
yeah he's just he's great personally
good advice from you said that when you
started dating Christian you intended to
go on paradise the whole time but if you
were feeling feelings for her why not
just stay what wasn't clicking a hundred
percent about things with Christian I
think it was my fear of commitment
I wasn't ready yet and I didn't know if
that's what I wanted I wanted to protect
myself so I kept it you know very
surface level and didn't really let her
in kept it light yeah that's a very
light because then on the show you
started to say to Hanna when she came
and also to Derek wait this is more
serious I may have been downplaying this
what was that realization you were
having that I actually cared about her a
lot more than I thought I did sometimes
it's hard to admit we care right I know
and trying to keep it cool the whole
time and then not being around her at
all and still thinking about her
whenever I'm exploring a relationship
with an amazing man it was confusing for
me but I mean it is amazing he's the
best isn't he he really is I mean when
you look back tell me about that breakup
moment with him how hard that was oh my
gosh that was one of the hardest things
ever had to do because I didn't want her
anybody yeah but the way that he
responded it just went to prove how
amazing he is respectful King yeah sure
I Derek now has this rallying cry people
wanting him to be the bachelor I know
where do you fall on that I mean I will
support him whatever he wants to do I
just want him to be happy but are you
gonna campaign for that like Darren I'm
here for you I mean you tweet a lot are
you on the derek for bachelor hashtag
train well you know I'm just trying to
like get through paradise and you know
there it's still on paradise true though
you know have you talked to him do you
know if he's found love I've talked to
Derek but we don't talk about our love
life together anymore
we just like to keep it fun okay it's
still a little weird I mean cuz you did
day yeah I don't think it's weird
I just think that it's easier whenever
we're just talking like making jokes and
stuff keeping it light yes give it a
flip in it like isn't it funny making
sure we're good
we'll say he's single hypothetically do
you support Derek for bachelor would you
be out there and and campaigning for
that i 100% would support him I wouldn't
want to campaign because what if some of
my other friends want the gig to you
know do you have a pick for bachelor
that's not Derek then I don't have a
pick for bachelor heck okay you gotta
have somebody you'd want who you think
would be good I think that any of the
potentials right now our most
frontrunners yeah why do you think Derek
would make a good bachelor if he ended
up in the park I think it's because he's
mature yeah and he obviously knows how
to have good conversations and even
tough conversations and he makes people
feel good and he really is a good guy
yeah yes I think he blew everybody away
with just how he handled the whole thing
anyway yeah oh yeah what was going
through your mind during all that when
he was responding and listening to the
stuff you were telling him I was like oh
thank god like I mean it was still
really sad and it still was an emotional
conversation but I was just like how is
this guy real he's pretty unreal yeah
he's also a John Krasinski doppelganger
Tatia celebrity I do want to ask you a
little bit about some criticism you've
gotten and I think it's hard because it
is such an important moment for the
franchise to see a queer relationship on
screen it's magnificent it is empowering
to people it's inspiring but at the same
time you've even had some people in
bachelor nation coming after you tanner
Tolbert said
that you went into the show just like
Jed Wyatt with these intentions to
produce a relationship for yourself what
do you say to those accusations I think
it's a unique situation I know that I
was always open and honest and
communicated exactly what I was feeling
and what I was going through and that's
where it's very much different from Jed
I wasn't hiding anything from anyone I
kept everyone on the same page as I was
experience the experiencing the emotions
that I was yeah so it's nothing like
well he has said that you had this plan
always to bring Christian on the show
and Colton Underwood you were on his
season Colton commented on Tanner's
Instagram and said can confirm what do
you think about Colton supporting
Tanner's allegations they weren't there
they don't know the story everyone saw
exactly how it happened
you saw that on TV that it wasn't
pre-planned so for the record did you go
into paradise with any thought that
Christian might show up there I was
always honest and I was open with all
the producers and everyone and I knew
that there could be a chance that my
past relationships would come up in any
way so yeah I was always open about it
did you go into it definitely planning
to bring Christian to paradise no okay I
didn't know if I could find love on
paradise with someone who was already
there for bachelor nation did you go
into paradise with the intention of I'm
going to get engaged here absolutely not
I kind of like mocked people who got
engaged there in the beginning because I
was like there's no way so I went in
thinking absolutely no way so you and
Christians seem really deeply in love
right away in Paradise you exchanged I
love yous what can you tease about how
things go for you guys I will say that
the relationship is not perfect after
she gets there I know we emotionally
connected so quickly but it was still a
real relationship and we have struggles
and lots of Tears are you engaged
I cannot say when Christian showed up
did you change your mind a little bit
about maybe whether or not you could get
engaged I for the first time whenever
she showed up I realized that I could
potentially want to be with this person
forever this is a person I can see
myself with forever okay and that was
the first time I've ever felt
thing like that a lot of people have
also asked why Christians stayed on the
beach some people have argued about the
format of the show and I mean look at
the end of the day I know there really
are no rules it's a TV show but some
people are saying if you guys know you
loved each other why not just leave
paradise together why didn't you why did
she stay in the real world there's so
many distractions that you don't have in
paradise
and we wouldn't have been able to have
the conversations that we had in
Paradise and experience that focus that
you have on your relationship that's all
you're doing in the real world you know
you have a life to get back to so it was
just a great opportunity for us to
really get to know each other more and
explore the relationship in such a
magical place how did you handle that
with Derek though like did you try to
avoid him so he didn't have to say you
know they're being so awesome and
respectful like honestly we hung out
with him all the time yeah and we always
see him and Christian off in the corner
talking I was like this is so weird but
hey I'm cool with it
so what maybe came friendly yeah
everyone was friendly like oh yeah it's
totally cool wow this is like the most
mature situation in the history of the
bachelor frame no darre okay well and it
lends me to think like God you know
people say a lot we want a guy who's
ready for love we want a mature guy
we're more I am thinking Derek for
patchable and he's really so great
there's also been some talk about some
funnier stuff in Paradise some critiques
on Jay PJ's kissing house derek is a
kisser Derek's a great kisser
yeah for sure okay so we support Derek
in that realm too oh yes dan what can
you tease for me about that fight that
we see coming up between JPJ and Derek
that's been all in all the trailers and
it's kind of striking to see these two
pretty amicable guys yelling at each
other it was pretty scary to see two
guys who I really enjoy hanging out with
screaming at each other I didn't like
seeing the mad side at JPJ
yeah confusing oh my gosh I don't even
know what they were fighting about we're
also going to see a paradise wedding
crystal and Chris get married what can
you tease about that an emotional night
what was like oh it was so beautiful it
was very emotional and it's so weird
because you're all sitting there at this
wedding with you know the person your
love interest at the time and there's so
much love in the air
so kyo does that speed things up I mean
if you're there with someone and you're
falling for them and then you're
watching a wedding yeah and you're like
and these people got engaged doing what
we're doing right now like this is how
they got here okay yeah it's pretty
crazy
does that make you change your
perspective a little maybe it just you
know give me a good feeling we love a
good feeling so when it comes to the
franchise you guys are the first queer
relationship we've ever seen on screen
and it's a milestone but given the
format how does the show handle that
from here do you think there are more
queer relationships on screen what do
they do you know I really don't want to
be the one to carry the torch for how
bachelor nation should handle that so
you know I don't know well how do you
feel about when people are criticizing
the format and saying that you know the
rules were broken with you guys that
kind of thing I would say that there are
no rules and the show is about finding
love and pursuing that and that's what
we're doing so did you find love I mean
yes we said I love you to each other
you've been really funny on the beach -
Demi you really you lay it out at people
you tell them what you're thinking how
did you feel about kind of being the
queen of paradise oh I felt rightfully
in my place I had so much fun anybody
you would want to set Hannah up with you
played a little bit of a part in her
season oh my gosh the Opera the options
are endless at this point it's Hannah
Brown the Bachelorette yeah whoever she
wants and Hannah Brown of Dancing with
the Stars oh my gosh I can't wait I
can't wait to watch her win oh how much
is she gonna slay oh she's gonna kill it
she's been dancing her whole life well
and you live in LA now no they do those
trio dances oh my god she better bring
me back you know she's bringing me okay
we're gonna see Demi brunette dancing oh
my gosh I'm so weird I don't even know
if I'm good in the audience though at
least yeah yeah for sure
Kaelyn in the Blake situation she's been
getting some heat for allegedly faking
her feelings people have pointed out
that on your season during the women
tell all she seemed really distraught
over Colton but people have argued she
was actually dating Blake at the time
what do you think about that whole
history I think that they both just
they've like been through enough with
everything the Internet has like reamed
them both at this point I think we just
need to uplift everyone and just be kind
I mean Blake's taking a lot of heat are
you are you taking a turn on Blake do
you say lay off Blake or do you think he
still deserves the criticism I say lay
off Blake I say like let's just move on
guys like it it's not helpful to be
critical of people and to be mean to
them it's more helpful just to be nice
to them and lift them up in this dark
dark time by the way another little
celebrity friend we saw you hanging out
with Demi Lovato at the taping are you
guys staying in touch Demi and Demi yes
we actually do you stay in touch I know
it's so weird like what is my life what
is your life like I just go back to that
girl who made her Instagram name Demi
not Lovato and I just want to be like
girl you go meet Demi Lovato you should
change that I mean you can update the
handle it's just too good at this point
everyone knows it right
I mean Hannah changed from Alabama
Hannah she's just Hannah Brown now yeah
heartbroken about that all right
yes distraught well why I just loved
Alabama Hannah um so what are you Demi
Lovato talking about oh we're just
talking about meeting up and watching
the show together okay yeah and maybe if
Mike's single maybe her and Mike
together Oh would that be something
I mean Tyler's with a supermodel Mike's
with a singer everybody can just combine
all the worlds of slaves happening what
is happening
[Music]